good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight we're having a lot of
gun control debates this week and it's
possible you've heard an advocate for
gun control say that in this country we
have more Firearms than civilian hands
than we have civilian hands and that is
true actually the total American
population is about 332 million people
and collectively they own more than 400
million firearms about half of all U.S
households have at least one gun at home
and many have much more than that plus
they have ammo billions and billions of
rounds of it
those are all real numbers but they are
hardly an argument for gun control
they're an argument in fact against it
ask yourself what would it require to
confiscate all those guns and all that
ammunition and turn the United States
into a disarmed Nation like Turkmenistan
or North Korea well it would take a
police state and it would end in Civil
War no sane person wants either one of
those things but thankfully we don't
need them
the fact that so many Americans have a
firearm Within Reach but never commit
violence tells you that guns are not the
problem most people in this country can
be trusted with an AR-15 just as we can
be trusted with cars and light aircraft
and electricity and baseball bats and
insecticide and chainsaws and pruning
shears and countless other objects it
could easily double as weapons
on some level all of us understand this
the problem is always the person not the
tool he uses to commit a crime if you
wanted to stop murder you would focus on
the people who were committing murder
not on the hundreds of millions of their
neighbors who are not
you'd really want to know what motivated
Killers to kill and the first thing you
would do is study what murders have in
common with one another how they were
raised and where their educational
backgrounds their genetic makeup drug
and alcohol use their ideological and
religious views their sexual behavior
and probably a whole lot of other
factors you would study murderers and
you would do it with an open mind as a
scientist would you would be serious
about it because it matters
in the late 19th century researchers
finally decided that infection is spread
by germs and as a result of that
conclusion surgeons are now required to
wash their hands before they cut you
open everybody agrees that this is
progress
but what if we had refused to learn how
infection is spread what if we just
didn't want to know
well appendectomies would still be fatal
and we would be a backward ridiculous
uncaring people
it's impossible even to imagine that and
yet on the question of violent crime of
murder
it's very easy to imagine that because
it's happening our leaders are
determined not to know why people shoot
each other and they don't want us to
know either they're adamant that we do
not ask questions about motive
it seems for example like an awful lot
of mass Shooters have taken prescription
psychiatric drugs in the days before
they opened fire and killed others have
you noticed that maybe you have noticed
that good luck saying it in public
you'll be shouted down immediately by
someone with an advanced degree how dare
you criticize big Pharma what are you a
conspiracy nut
no actually you're not you're someone
who cares about cause and effect you're
a rational person
the only conspiracy here is the one to
design to prevent you from figuring out
why mass shootings keep happening
consider the killings that took place on
Monday in Nashville the killer was a 28
year old female transgenderist who shot
her way into a Christian Elementary
School and murdered three nine-year-olds
and three adults
why did she do that
in a rational country that is the very
first question we would ask in our
country it's the last question in fact
often it's never asked at all
on those rare occasions when somebody
finally manages to wonder out loud about
motive our leaders immediately start
lying which should tell you a lot
here's the Attorney General of the
United States yesterday
I realized that the shooter is dead but
the shooter
could have had collaborators
do you plan on on opening a hate crime
investigation
for the targeting of Christians
the FBI and ATF are both on the scene
working with the local police as of now
a motive hasn't been identified and the
police chief said at the last as last
press conference that they don't yet
have reached a conclusion with respect
to motive we are certainly working full
time with them to try and determine what
the motive is and of course motive is
what determines whether it's a hate
crime or not
so here's what we just learned from
Merrick Garland the FBI the ATF and the
Nashville police are all investigating
these shootings yet more than 24 hours
after they took place none of those
professional investigators can even
guess as to why the shootings happened
motive hasn't been identified Garland
told us really
you wonder how that could possibly be
just before she opened fire the
Nashville shooter wrote these words to
her best friend over Instagram quote one
day this will make more sense I've left
behind more than enough evidence
that evidence includes a written
Manifesto where the killer spells out
exactly why she killed children
the FBI the ATF the Nashville police and
for that matter Merrick Garland all have
access to that Manifesto and yet somehow
the Attorney General informs us that a
motive has not yet been identified
well he's lying they all are lying we
can't see the manifesto because the
transgender Lobby which has far more
power than you do has pressured
politicians to keep it hidden but we can
be certain what it says Monday's victims
were murdered because they were
Christians
it's that simple transgenderous hate
Christians above all not because
Christians are a physical threat the
third graders were not a physical threat
but because Christians refused to join
every other liar in our society and
Proclaim that transgenderous are Gods
with the power to change nature itself
Christians are not allowed to say that
they have their own God
and for that refusal that unwillingness
to Bow Down and Worship a false idol in
this case of transgenderism they were
murdered we have never seen this battle
so starkly said as it is now
and it opens to us to our eyes the main
divide in America and it's not between
race or political party it's not even
between religious affiliation
The Divide is between people who think
they are God and those who know they are
not God
that is what the Nashville shooting was
about is what virtually everything is
about
that conflict exists because these two
groups could not be more different they
will be forever at odds with one another
and they always have been
people who know they're not God are by
definition restrained they understand
the limits of their own power and of
their virtue they appreciate the
complexity of the world which they
freely admit they don't really
understand because no human can fully
understand it
they may not always be good people but
they are certainly less dangerous people
if only because their Ambitions are
limited by the acknowledgment of reality
only God can do certain things and they
know they are not him
now people who think they are God are
not like this at all people who believe
their God have no natural limits because
God has no limits nor do they have any
real concern for others they are their
own God they worship themselves
in Freudian terms they are narcissists a
narcissists admit no fault they
externalize everything they always blame
others
so not surprisingly given this
transgenderous and their allies spent
today attacking Christians just days
after a transgenderous murdered
Christian children
here's congresswoman Catherine Clark of
Massachusetts on the house floor
layered in my pride is my concern for
you
I know your strength but I also know how
determined the forces are that have
pitted themselves against you the
politicians and preachers who would
rather see you languish in a dark closet
than watch you engage the world as you
do cultivating joy and love wherever you
go let's reject the forces of opposition
and bigotry let's celebrate the bravery
and beauty of our trans community
cultivating joy and love wherever you go
this in response to the murder of
children by a self-described trans
person you're the victim transgenderous
not the dead children in Nashville and
of course virtually everyone in power in
this country agreed Amazon the company
sent an email to its employees from its
lgbtq plus Department assuring its trans
employees that they were affirmed and
they were great people no mention
whatsoever
of the dead children in Nashville
their concern was the only concern and
then NBC News ran this headline one of
many like it Tennessee's trans
communities concerned because of the
focus on the identity of the shooter no
update from NBC on how the Christian
Community in Nashville is doing because
who cares they're just Mortals their
concerns aren't meaningful
Joe Biden certainly doesn't care watch
him chuckle as he talks about Monday's
Massacre
[Applause]
[Music]
well I have no idea
people who believe their God will always
turn their rage and frustration outward
they will never blame themselves how
could they they are God
so you should not be surprised to learn
that in the wake of this shooting when
their agenda is revealed for all to see
there will be no Contrition no changing
of ways there will only be acceleration
and there will be more violence coming
and they're telling us that
the press secretary for the governor of
Arizona Katie Hobbs someone called
Jocelyn Berry who was just resigned
apparently uploaded this Photograph
hours after the killing along with the
message us when we see transphobes
a woman with a gun in her hand hours
after a woman with a gun in her hand
killed Christian children in Nashville
in other words the Christians had it
coming
don't affirm our delusions we will
murder you
again this is someone who works for the
moderate governor of Arizona who beat
the radical Cary Lake
and once again this will continue and it
will gather speed because the more they
are revealed the more they double down
they can never admit they are wrong
because they believe they are Gods with
the power to control nature so once
again you should not be surprised at all
that there was something called the
trans day of Vengeance coming this
weekend planned by antifa in Washington
DC it was originally called the trans
day of visibility but the trans radical
activist Network the organizers decide
to change the name just before the
massacre in Nashville now it's a trans
day of Vengeance and they mean Vengeance
Vengeance for what that's not clear
they've been caught
and so they become more aggressive
as people who worship themselves always
do and you can see it all over social
media threatening images everywhere one
trans activist posted this message
yesterday quote kill Christ behead
Christ cucks roundhouse kick a Christ
cuck into the concrete slam dunk a
christ-cock baby into the trash can
attached to this post is an image of
someone holding a rifle and wearing body
armor
now you would think in a country
supposedly as sensitive to violences
ours run by an Administration that wants
to end gun violence that the justice
department be all over this because
they're terrified of course of groups
with guns who are organized trying to
upset the social order but in this case
they're not terrified at all they have
no problem with this whatsoever we
called the doj today to ask what are you
doing about this they didn't bother to
get back to us
meanwhile the tech Barons are as always
making sure you don't even know what's
happening Twitter which was supposed to
be free has banned several users users
including a sitting member of Congress
Marjorie Taylor Greene and Dino Sean
Davis for mentioning the existence of
the trans day of Vengeance you're not
supposed to know what's coming
the head of trust at Twitter a woman
called Ella Irwin is deliberately
silencing reporting on this day of
vengeance
because again
it's coming
but you shouldn't be allowed to prepare
for it subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight